and more than 50 000 train workers are  expected to strike  on three days this week strikes will  take place on tuesday thursday and  saturday  but severe delays are expected all week  many companies are telling people to try  to avoid traveling entirely  workers in england will be striking but  services in scotland and wales are also  going to be affected  and these are all the companies that are  involved  the network rail says just over one in  five of the normal number of trains will  run and they'll start later and finish  earlier than usual  the rmt union leading the strike argue  that its members have experienced pay  freezes threats to jobs and attacks on  their terms and conditions and the talks  to try to resolve those issues have  broken down today